ich bin mit der luft aufklärer und
auswerte unteroffizier bei der
luftaufklärung und langen leben meine
aufgaben umfassen die planung und
durchführung von militärischen und unter
anderem auch die bodenluft bedarf
bringen
[Musik]
wir beginnen mit der flugvorbereitung
das heißt mehr planen die flüge gehen
dann zusammen mit dem bedeuten zum
fluggerät und führen anschließend sein
auftrag durch
[Musik]
nach der landung werden die aufnahmen
ausgewertet und an die jeweiligen
auftraggeber ausgeliefert
[Musik]
ich bin hubschrauber techniker am black
hawk da fast jeden tag der hubschrauber
zu flugdienst verwendet wird ist es
eigentlich meine mein tägliches brot
landes sowie eine tägliche aufgabe die
erste kontrolle vor dem flug zu führen
bzw den piloten bei übungen und
einsätzen bei der landung einzuweisen
bzw
die außen das 2 1 zu weisen dass sie auf
den punkt landet wo sie letzten endes
sein soll
[Musik]
der kader ist der einzige heute
hubschrauber müsst ihr euch 100er daraus
ergebe sich dann in weiterer folge auch
die die einsatzaufgaben meine aufgabe in
der heutigen übung ist wer begleitschutz
des black hawks plus die aufklärung des
weges und der landes ohne im der damen
weiterer folge die truppen und die außen
das tab gesetzt werden
[Musik]